[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain a french comedy film called
serial teachers spoilers ahead watch out
and take
[Music]
care in a school in france 86 of
students have successfully graduated
this year which is the highest record of
all time they run around and dance
hopeful for a thriving college life
ahead meanwhile in jules ferry high
school the environment is the exact
opposite the news channels report it as
the least ranked high school of the year
with only a 12 percent pass rate the
academy inspector deputy inspector and
the principal are in a meeting
discussing the students poor performance
they have employed the best teachers in
the city and the students aren't dumb
asses either which makes it difficult
for them to understand the cause of
failure if the pass rate doesn't rise up
to at least 50 percent this year the
sponsors will stop funding the school
and it will have to be closed to avoid
this they come up with a new strategy
that no one has ever tried before they
want to appoint the worst teachers in
the country since the best ones didn't
give them the results they wanted they
are hopeful the worst ones will make a
difference that logic checks out then we
are introduced to the said worst
teachers first is the aggressive english
teacher miss gladys she is great at what
she does only a little too violent
towards the dumb students then there is
the lazy math teacher kutiro he is so
slow that when he goes fishing the
fishes pull him into the water the
sports teacher eric uses anything heavy
to lift and anything flat as a frisbee
fourth is the chemistry teacher albert
his experiments are life threatening and
so are his classes maurice is the
teacher of philosophy who says things in
riddles and makes them more complicated
than they really are amina is the french
teacher the hottest one in the lot
students love her class because of her
excellent teaching methods but mostly
because of the revealing clothes then
there is polichon the history teacher he
is shy and chaotic definitely the one
who used to be bullied in high school
the team of losers enters the school
together catching everyone's attention
gladys takes the first class and starts
hitting the kids with pieces of chalk
instantly she seems to enjoy bullying
them more than teaching them one of the
students is nectarine the usual
teacher's pet and the only one who
studies she skipped the grade last year
because of her amazing grades and
doesn't forget to mention it every
chance she gets then we are introduced
to the class clown who is always late
bouyard he enters the classroom and
instantly becomes a victim of gladys's
assault the entire classroom is stunned
by her unique but mostly frightening
personality the next class is kotiros
being the lazy man he is he comes 20
minutes late and takes an extra 10
minutes to write his name on the board
then he takes a smoke break and stays
outside until the period ends the
history teacher polichon enters the
wrong classroom and finds the german
teacher in the front he mistakes her for
a student and asks her to join the
others the teacher tries explaining but
poli-chan doesn't listen after awkwardly
fidgeting with papers and talking about
napoleon for a few minutes he is told he
is in the wrong class he apologizes
before rushing out at lunch break
polichon and the german teacher share
glances indicating the start of a
romantic relationship during gym class
the sports teacher makes the students
climb trees without any safety measures
when they hurt themselves he dismisses
it as one of many problems they will
face in life then it's time for the
student's favorite miss amina's class
the guys look at her for the first time
and forget to blink when she brings them
out of their heads all of them fall down
without missing a beat bouyard arrives a
bit late but has the same reaction in
the philosophy period the teacher puts
his coat over a guy's head and calls him
a talking coat hanger he explains how a
hanger cannot talk for the entire period
lastly in chemistry class albert mixes
some chemicals but because of a slight
mistake in measurement the entire class
is covered in fizz after school polichon
approaches the french teacher and
apologizes for his mistake he also picks
her up in a hug unaware of proper
etiquette having never touched a woman
in his life the seven losers teach the
students for a week which is the most
chaotic week in the history of jules
ferry by the weekend parents arrive with
complaints like the chemistry teacher
burning someone's bag and the sports
teacher sending students home with a
different broken bone every day it is
the last straw for the principal before
calling the academy deputy inspector but
the man couldn't care less how he
handles the situation he was the one who
pitched the idea of worst teachers but
his dismissal of the situation makes the
principal think he had an ulterior
motive behind it the next day the
principal takes matters into his own
hands and tries his best to mold the
teacher to his ways first he glues the
pieces of chalk onto the table so gladys
won't be able to hit the students when
she resorts to the duster instead the
string attached to it hits her back in
the face then when it is kotiro's class
he brings out a picnic chair to rest on
it as usual but this time a short
circuit causes a small explosion making
him jump when he decides to end the
class early the principal pretends to be
the clock on the wall and reminds him of
the time polichon's problem is that he
cannot stop talking about napoleon so
the principal interrupts the class with
a powerpoint presentation on the topic
he is supposed to teach for the
chemistry period he locks all the
chemicals except for water so that no
more explosions take place also
presumably so that the students learn
nothing to get rid of amina's revealing
clothes the radiator is broken and
everyone has to wear layers of clothing
in the meantime polochan is still
attempting to impress the german teacher
he asks his colleagues for help who
suggest he act tough whenever she is
near polochan takes the suggestion
seriously and pretends to be a typical
bad boy after school he shows off his
non-existent muscles and asks her out on
a date however he realizes he is doing
something wrong when she refuses it is
finally the end of the term the teachers
have been depressed lately because of
all the restrictions they have been put
through so when the deputy inspector
comes for an inspection they complain
about all their problems he sees a
pattern that the principal is too
invested in the teacher's way of working
hence he gives them the absolute right
to their classes now that the group can
do whatever they want they do not hold
back polichon teaches about napoleon
while cosplaying as him while a lazy
khatiro rests on a hammock for the
entire class in one of gladys's classes
bouyard pulls on nectarine's hair making
her whine as a solution gladys chops off
her ponytail since she has the right to
do whatever she wants in class the
principal cannot do anything about it
the chemistry teacher takes the most
advantage of the freedom his experiments
go from absurd to life-threatening
almost every class ends up in some kind
of explosion the philosophy teacher
makes his pupils walk around naked to
teach them about nature in its deepest
form these teachers should all go to
jail by now the school has caught the
neighborhood kids attention they hear
stories about a hot teacher explosive
classes and classes where they can get
naked in a few weeks people start to
break into the school to attend it the
attendance percentage goes up a hundred
and twenty percent the school turns into
a club and the teachers become
celebrities among the newcomers
meanwhile polachon is still trying his
best to impress the german teacher this
time he attempts to sweep her off her
feet by pretending to be a prince on a
horse the plan fails though when the
horse runs away as the final term nears
the extra students are refrained from
coming to school the others take a mock
test to prepare for the finals however
the results show that the pass rate has
dropped from 12 percent to 3 percent the
teachers do not know what to think of it
the principal is also shocked that the
pass rate could go any lower he meets
the deputy inspector and tells him that
his plan is not working it is then
revealed that the man never wanted it to
work he wants to get the pass rate as
low as possible so the academy inspector
would be fired and he could take over
the position he knew the new teachers
would fail which is why he appointed
them polichon overhears the conversation
and runs to his colleagues to tell them
after finding out they are france's
worst teachers the group is determined
to prove otherwise polichon gets the
idea to steal the exam papers the others
join in and they start making an
elaborate plan to do so they even
practice dodging bullets in case they
are caught then the execution day
finally arrives the group joins a crowd
protesting outside the ministry when the
police chase the crowd away gladys lies
down on the road and goes unnoticed then
while gladys and ketiro wait outside the
others barge into the ministry amina
distracts the guards with her beauty
letting the group enter the building and
into the protected room but an
unpredicted problem arises when the safe
has a lock that needs a six-digit code
to be opened suddenly khatiro walks in
proving that they didn't have to do all
the work to get inside together they
assumed the code must be the day the
minister won the election which turns
out to be true in the following scene
the students are asked to take a second
mock test the group hints at how
important the questions are and starts
the test however they find out that they
accidentally stole the middle school
exam papers still the students
appreciate the effort they made with
only two weeks left for the finals
everyone loses hope polichon goes to the
principal with his resignation letter
knowing that nothing he does will help
the students now as he is leaving the
school premises the german teacher
expresses how disappointed she is in him
for running away like a coward her
comment makes him realize he is not
ready to give up yet he motivates the
students and the teachers citing
napoleon and convinces them to study
hard for the next two weeks starting
that day the philosophy teacher drinks
before teaching so the students
understand what he is saying gladys
allows them to wear helmets so they
won't be hurt when she throws pieces of
chalk at them and the sports teacher
trains them harder than ever three weeks
later the results are published to
everyone's surprise the students show
the biggest rise in pass rate but it
only reaches 49 percent this means the
teachers are unsuccessful and the school
won't be in operation anymore the deputy
inspector celebrates his win by drinking
in front of his boss and revealing it
was his plan all along what an idiot
just as everything is going downhill the
principal receives a letter that changes
everything because of bouillard's
repeated bad performance in school he is
expelled one less failure means that the
pass rate rises to 50 percent all thanks
to bouillard's stupidity everyone
celebrates the win and treats him like a
prince after that as per the agreement
the teachers are allowed to transfer to
any school they want but they all decide
to remain in jules ferris for the half
of the students who didn't pass
somewhere else the deputy inspector is
riding a boat on a river filled with
crocodiles it turns out he was
transferred to a rural village by his
boss in the last scene we see the german
teacher kiss polichon before they click
a group picture for the yearbook
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching